never see anybody do an hour here you
know you see everybody do their spot you
see everybody dick around with 10
minutes being in Portland going to
helium there and watching my friends
come through but do their hours now I
sit and I watch what they are presenting
to uh somebody who paid to be at the
club and it's so rewarding to see the
final product like I went and saw the
scar Brothers their hour I was like
howling I was like having a great time
at the with everybody else in the
audience that's awesome just oh I tried
to do Edinburgh once didn't go well but
I've done some other festiv has it gone
well for anyone ever besides Phoebe
Waller bridge I mean it's like everyone
I know that goes there like you go for
30 days it sucks there's no one in the
audience and then you get reviewed by a
journalist on a show that you didn't
know and there's five people there and
you got poisoning from the black mold
because my my venue was literally a
dungeon